if you thought brexit's problems had all
been unpacked think again
whitstable and kent is famous for
oysters but for those who produce them
the cost of brexit is rising new rules
on the export of shellfish has left this
business 50 down already but the
post-treaty disputes are making things
worse
as a row over fishing rights escalated
so too did threats from the french
james's buyers got nervous he's had over
20 000 pounds worth of orders cancelled
this week coupled with kobe coupled with
brexit coupled with water quality from
southern water you know
this is the fourth thing in the space of
you know less than a year that's had a
massive impact on our industry you can't
just take away
that main market overnight and expect
these businesses to continue because
they're just not there's only so many
hits body punches you can take as a
business and come get back up and start
again fishing was the reason he voted
for brexit the reality he says is not
what was promised
the deal we got was very very poor
very poor so
i probably would change my vote if i'm
honest do you feel that the government
have let you down i think
in a word yes
in paris this week it was all handshakes
and smiles for those tasks to resolve
this but there's tension here too and no
progress
the french say there are too few
licenses for boats like this that have
historically fished in uk waters
they threatened to tighten import checks
and block british boats from landing
their catch
it's retaliation this crew would support
the captains fished in british seas
since the 90s he's not yet been granted
a licence and he's getting desperate
[Music]
and as businesses still struggle the
context is a supply chain already
stacked up some say it can't cope with
much more
the impact of any further customs checks
or delays at ports will no doubt be felt
in the lorry parks across kent this one
was due to close soon to be replaced by
a bigger newer facility next door but
sky news understands the department for
transport has asked for it to remain
open for another couple of months over
christmas extra capacity perhaps for
extra pressure they suspect's coming
officials will talk again in the coming
days and while they're talking threats
are unlikely to be actioned on different
sides of these waters there's different
sides to this story but ongoing disputes
are costing helen and smith sky news
whitstable in kent